donc quelques jours nous irons donc aux
ions pour désigner le président de la
République Bruno Millen et notre invité
bonjour et député de la 9e
circonscription élu du MoDem soutien de
la République en marche et donc du
président candidat Emmanuel Macron hier
se tenait donc se débat du second tour
de l'élection nous avions prévu
également ce jeudi de vous faire
débattre face au rassemblement national
sur ce plateau mais son responsables
dans le département nous a signifié et
je vais reprendre ces termes que le
déchaînement des médias en général en
vert leurs candidates les elles obligent
à annuler débat et interview dont acte
est nouveau recevons seul aujourd'hui
pour débuter j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment sur les échanges de mercredi
soir comment avez-vous jugé la
prestation de votre candidat alors je
vais commencer peut-être sur la
prestation de des deux candidats en fait
le débat était plus intéressant qu'en
2017 parce que plus posé finalement plus
calme on a pu entendre vraiment le fond
des projets de et de l'autre et ça
c'était important parce que du coup ça a
donné un éclairage beaucoup plus
significatif que ce qu'on avait pu avoir
en 2017 alors on s'est aperçu d'un côté
qu'il y avait un projet chiffré il y
avait l'expérience du président de la
République et de l'autre côté un projet
plus porté sur les slogans on l'a vu ça
a commencé très mal pour Marine Le Pen
avec le pouvoir d'achat ou finalement il
a pas été compliqué de démonter le fait
que son pouvoir d'achat basé simplement
pas que simplement mais en partie sur la
baisse des TVA ne tenait pas et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on dénonce déjà depuis
des mois qui malheureusement n'a pas été
souvent repris dans les médias en
général
la TVA la baisse de la TVA d'abord c'est
quelque chose de terriblement injuste
puisque ça profite en réalité au plus
riche puisque ce sont eux qui consomment
le plus donc c'est eux qui en
bénéficient le plus et puis si on prend
par exemple ne serait-ce que le panier
d'aménagère je vais pas rentrer dans les
chiffres mais si on prend que le panier
d'aménagère c'est quand même une
économie globalement de 13 euros par
ménage et par an en global et pour les
30% les plus retrouve seulement de 10
euros par ménage et par an ce qui est
beaucoup moins finalement que à la fois
le chèque inflation le chèque énergie ou
le chèque
alimentation pour mettre sur ce point
précis d'ailleurs du pouvoir d'achat
dans un instant mais juste avant de
parler un peu plus de du fond sur la
forme il a été aussi peut-être reproché
encore une fois Emmanuel Macron d'avoir
été peut-être un peu plus hautain
d'avoir été plus distant et alors que la
compassion c'est plus ressenti du côté
de Marine Le Pen aussi en fait chacun
c'est un peu adressé assis à celui du
temps
on l'a bien vu sur l'histoire de la TVA
franchement que la TVA bénéficié à
Marine Le Pen n'a pas besoin c'est pas
de la compassion vis-à-vis des gens qui
n'ont pas de pouvoir d'achat de l'autre
côté on peut on peut le voir de deux
façons différentes une attitude du
président de la République d'abord il y
avait des passages qui étaient moi
j'étais j'ai regardé attentivement
c'était des passages qui étaient très
énervants je pense qu'il a quand même
gardé son calme assez de manière assez
royale ou présidentielle je sais pas
comment on peut dire ça parce que parce
que il quand même des énormités qui
étaient sorties donc on peut analyser ça
comme étant certains vont le dire
quelque chose dans l'attitude du
président qui peut paraître hautain et
d'autres comme quelque chose de plus de
pugnacité et de volonté de prouver que
c'est pas vrai voilà donc il y a deux
façons de voir les choses vous avez
parlé de du fond pour y revenir sur les
propositions pouvoir d'achat c'était
l'un des premiers sujets qui a été
abordé lors du débat d'hier
proposition de base de TVA proposition
du côté de votre candidat sur les fameux
chèques qui sont distribués chaque
alimentaire il y a eu aussi le bouclier
sur le gaz l'électricité remise à la
pompe aussi de 18 centimes qui se
répondant maintenu quoi qu'il en soit
quand on écoute le débat d'hier on a
quand même le sentiment qu'il y a encore
de l'argent magique en France non
on peut oui on parle de 600 milliards de
dates on part sur une déficit de balance
commerciale de 85 milliards oui oui non
mais on peut considérer ça comme ça on
est dans une situation de crise
exceptionnelle dans le débat on avait
l'impression que oui il y avait des
solutions que ce soit des déchets des
TVA vous avez deux vous avez deux façons
vous avez deux deux projets totalement
différents d'un côté effectivement on
aide et on soutient le temps qu'il faut
le temps qu'il faut pour venir en aide
au ménage les plus modestes c'est toute
la panoplie des chèques qu'on a mis en
place c'est aussi le bouclier tarifaire
sur l'énergie et mais ce sont des
mesures provisoires c'est pas la même
chose que de baisser la TVA de manière
pérenne ad vitam eternam qu'il a fait un
trou au niveau du budget de l'État qui
est considérable je crois que de mémoire
pour pour
si on prend que l'essence à la pompe
c'est quelque chose de l'ordre de 10
milliards si on prend le panier de la
ménagère c'est de l'ordre de 3 milliards
8 et ça c'est pérenne c'est quelque
chose que que vous perdez tout le temps
et régulièrement alors que de l'autre
côté effectivement ce sont des mesures
qui sont temporaires qui resteront le
temps qu'il faut mais le jour où la
situation va mieux ça s'arrête mais
c'est pas la même chose mais aujourd'hui
on continue de creuser en tout cas mais
oui mais enfin quelque part alors il y a
connaissez pas à la veille de ce second
tour aussi avoir un discours de vérité
envers les électeurs que de leur dire et
on pourrait parler aussi de la retraite
et l'âge de la retraite sur lesquels
chacun des deux candidats ont pas
forcément été le plus très clair et on a
bien senti un peu gêné aux en tournures
parce que quoi qu'il en soit il faudra
travailler plus il faudra rembourser
cette dette il faudra en trouver de
l'argent et de ce côté là Marine Le Pen
et pas très clair dans son projet parce
qu'en réalité si vous dites pour les
moins de 20 ans c'est 40 annuités et ils
partent à 60 ans pour tout le reste
c'est plutôt 67 que 64 donc voyez déjà
et puis il y a pas que ça dans le projet
de la réforme de retraite du président
de la République bien évidemment l'âge
de la retraite c'est un problème on l'a
vu c'est ce qui nous a aussi coûté
pendant le mandat sur la réforme des
retraites moi j'aurais adoré qu'on fasse
la retraite universelle par point parce
que pour moi c'est la plus équitable et
quand on a commencé à parler
effectivement du seuil de l'âge de
départ à la retraite là ça a posé
problème et bon les Français n'en ont
pas voulu donc acte néanmoins on le sait
il va va falloir un moment ou un autre
contrat plus longtemps mais ça peut pas
être que dans un sens c'est pas
simplement le retarder là je départ à la
retraite il y a plein il y a plein de
d'autres mesures la retraite minimum à
1100 euros ça c'est quelque chose
d'important pour les gens qui ont les
plus petites retraites ça Marine Le Pen
ça n'existe pas chez elle je vais vous
prendre un autre exemple
l'accompagnement des seniors puisque
c'est bien de retarder parce qu'on en a
besoin de rééquilibrer les comptes pour
maintenir cette retraite par répartition
qui est quelque chose
d'intergénérationnel que le monde entier
nous envie mais il faut aussi s'occuper
de la problématique des seniors on va
dire 50-55 ans jusqu'à 65 ans pour qu'il
reste dans l'emploi et là il va y avoir
un effort il va y avoir un effort énorme
fait sur sur la formation
professionnelle et sur le tutorat et sur
le mentorat que par exemple les
Allemands savent très bien faire il faut
qu'on s'en inspire en quelques mots
parce qu'il y a d'autres sujets que
j'aurais souhaité aborder aussi on sent
si Emmanuel Macron est aussi rééluia il
y a une demande envers les entreprises
que les entreprises s'impliquent aussi
et je pense à ça notamment avec la prime
qui porte son nom la prime Macron
portait jusqu'à 6000 euros ça ça veut
dire aussi que les entreprises doivent
faire des efforts doivent prendre leur
part aussi alors de voler là-dessus
parce que ça c'est important vous allez
d'un côté l'augmentation du salaire
demandé aux entreprises de 10% mais bon
il y a des entreprises ça c'est la
proposition de Marine Le Pen mais il y a
des entreprises qui pourront pas le
faire honnêtement elles peuvent le faire
sur un one shot mais elles peuvent pas
le faire de manière régulière et encore
c'est des recettes qui rentrent moins
parce qu'on les on les exonère de toute
cotisations fiscale et de l'autre côté
c'est de dire que
j'ai perdu le fil c'est une proposition
d'Emmanuel Macron et qui était de
d'augmenter cette prime qui était versée
la prime l'idée c'est quoi c'est
aujourd'hui vous avez un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui versent dividendes à
leurs actionnaires demain ces
entreprises seront obligées d'abonder
pour les salariés de la même manière en
participation en intéressement on verra
et pour celles qui ne peuvent pas le
faire parce qu'elles ne verse pas de
dividendes d'accord on augmente la prime
Macron on la passe à 6000 euros ça veut
pas dire que tout le monde touchera 6000
euros mais dès que vous avez des
bénéfices ou en tout cas des dividendes
vous pouvez redistribuer à vos salariés
le pouvoir d'achat n'en a beaucoup parlé
au cours de cet échange c'est l'une des
préoccupations si ce n'est la première
des préoccupations des Français si on
peut voir un petit tableau avec les
chiffres qui ont été compilés par Ipsos
notamment et qui reviennent surtout ça
après occupation principale il y en a
d'autres aussi on en a peut-être un
petit peu moins parlé on entend toujours
un peu m'en parler c'est la question de
l'environnement même si là on a appris
que par Emmanuel Macron son prochain
Premier ministre s'il était réillé en
charge de cette question la plus
spécifiquement il y a la question de
l'immigration de la sécurité et de tout
ça on va pas avoir le temps de d'y
revenir mais ce n'était pas le but de
notre échange ce matin néanmoins il y a
un autre chiffre sur lequel je voudrais
vous faire réagir ça ça a été réalisé
avant le débat d'hier pour seulement 41
des pour cent des français Emmanuel
Macron veut vraiment changer les choses
c'est 63% pour Marine Le Pen
mais parce que peut-être nous on
s'inscrit dans une continuité de
l'action qu'on a commencé à mener on a
eu une première partie c'est pour ça
qu'un quinquennat ses cours on a une
première partie en plus on est on a
quand même subi quelques crises mais la
première partie c'était vraiment de
relancer l'économie pourquoi relancer
l'économie libérer l'économie libérer
les entreprises de manière à ce qu'elle
puisse être performante compétitive et
qu'elle crée de l'emploi c'est ce qui
s'est fait baisse du chômage comme on
n'a jamais vu notamment pour les jeunes
ça c'était pas vu depuis 40 ans et la
deuxième partie du projet initial du
président Macron c'est qu'une fois qu'on
a fait ça on attaque vraiment le social
pour par des réformes de fonds que ce
soit sur l'hôpital avec la santé que ce
soit on l'a vu sur les retraites mais
que ce soit l'apprentissage on a
commencé c'est un vrai succès voilà il y
a toutes ces mesures là donc d'un côté
effectivement il y a ça qui nous
continuité où on va accélérer de l'autre
côté c'est un programme de rupture mais
c'est un problème de rupture qui ne
tient pas qui va appauvrir les gens plus
que les gens ne le croient et avec
finalement un projet qui est fait de
slogan et qui se heurte à la réalité de
la vie de tous les jours mais par
rapport à
à cette situation est-ce que vous n'avez
pas peur non plus que ce soit une fois
de plus peut-être un vote contre et pas
un vote pour et il faudra composer
ensuite avec et puis composer aussi pour
le troisième tour celui des législatives
mais c'est compliqué c'est là on va pas
on va pas avoir le temps mais c'est là
où il va falloir un jour rebondir sur le
la réforme de nos institutions parce que
vous voyez bien que
l'élection du président a deux tours tel
que on l'a dans la constitution de 58
pose un problème au premier tour
forcément vous choisissez il y a
pléthore de candidat je crois on en
avait 12 donc forcément vous trouvez un
candidat qui vous ressemble le plus et
pour lequel vous allez voter et au
deuxième tour bah forcément il y a toute
une grande majorité de Français qui se
retrouvent qui s'y retrouve plus parce
qu'ils ont deux candidats qui n'ont pas
forcément choisi et là pour le coup
effectivement souvent et on l'a vu à
l'élection après l'élection il vote pour
celui ou celle qui considère comme étant
le moins pire pour eux ou le plus proche
entre guillemets de ce qu'il pense
effectivement faudra revenir sur ce
système des institutions et puis
peut-être sur les abstentions
l'abstentionnisme peut-être juste en
deux mots également vous vous êtes
beaucoup impliqué sur cette question là
vous avez lancé un groupe de réflexion
aussi ce sera notre mot de la fin
attentionniste vous leur dites quoi
dimanche pour qu'ils aient simplement
aux abstentionnistes que notre
démocratie est quand même bien faite
enfin on vit bien en France et que
l'abstention c'est la pire des réponses
puisque en fait vous faites du Nini et
vous donner des voix soit Alain soit à
l'autre en allant pas voter et après moi
je préfère que les gens aillent voter et
puis on leur a mis conscience à la
limite peut-être on parlait de la
réforme des institutions de penser à
faire quelque chose sur le vote blanc
mais l'accention c'est la pire des
choses quand vous vous abstenez
finalement bah vous pouvez difficilement
reprocher quoi que ce soit au vainqueur
dans l'application de son projet merci
Bruno millième député MoDem d'être venu
sur ce plateau à quelques jours du
second tour de l'élection présidentielle